is let me ask you this let me ask you
this let me ask you this so what is
today
in comedy what can't you touch because
like when i was watching hans do what he
was doing all he did is make fun of
asians but you can get away with it
because obviously he's and the jokes he
said by the way how many of them were
like crossing the line to the average
person every one of them right do it but
he can do it because he's asian yeah no
because here's why
yeah but let me ask the question and you
run it i want to hear from you because
you're so so what can't i touch
what can you touch what's gray area
what's super risky and who today can
touch anything and no one can say [ __ ]
about it right
so
the interesting thing and i'll go i'm
immediately going back because this is
the answer the reason why hans can do
that isn't because he's asian what's
interesting about what he's doing is
it's the fact that he's smiling big the
entire time he's likable he's he's
putting the jokes on himself
oftentimes in a in a separation
way he makes it about himself he even
though maybe he's not a liberal you know
i'm not speaking for him but he'll say
i'm a liberal so i
whatever i'm not going to do his jokes
but he puts it on him instead of making
fun of women he'll go i'm like a woman
i'm his insecure you know what i mean
whatever he's making fun of everything
at once with a smile the art form the
art form is
getting it across and making it work
that's why another interesting thing
that happened you know with my
this is him yep he is asian almost every
picture though look at him what do you
notice
look at this
and that second one of course
people are idiots how they found that
one of him not smiling it's like
he is asian what do you mean
yeah okay so yeah well i mean that's
what i'm saying is that that's what i do
too is it's about it's about getting the
things across it's about making it work
if you're up there and you're literally
you know and that is to my to my own uh
judgment here like i'm sort of burying
myself because one thing that i didn't
do
in the video that got me in trouble was
smile a lot but it's because the reason
why i did what happened there was
because his whole thing before the five
minutes of his set before i went up was
white people are so mean and he was
doing things to try to get
like not a sympathy applause break but
not funny deep stuff like all that we we
this this this and you're expecting a
joke and he basically goes like all we
want white people is for you to be nice
to us yeah and it's like i'm standing in
the back getting ready to go on and i
think to myself the funniest thing i
could do right now on a thursday night
where phones are supposed to be locked
up
uh it's my
show i'm the surprise on this show like
it's not my show my show i wasn't
headlining that show that was a workout
set on a show called a secret show it's
the secret show every thursday because
you don't know who's going to you're
dropping right i'm a drop in it's where
i work out stuff that i thought about
driving there or
yesterday in the shower or whatever it's
a place talk you're tight it's not your
type 20 you're just you're testing [ __ ]
out exactly and because he was going
white people are so mean white people
are so mean and then it's five minutes
of white people are so mean and at that
point i'm like i'm going to i'm going to
go 100 miles an hour here the funniest
thing i can do after his set and sure
enough again you know when when the
whole thing was breaking
what's his name from tmz harvey whoever
of course he took the interview this
this [ __ ] comedian that tried to do
this to me and he took the interview and
uh with harvey and he even he goes all i
heard in that video was some laughter
and he goes well yeah but you should
have seen the looks on the people's
faces i'm like what what what
what are we talking about here
so back to pat's original question
what's off limits what's great nothing
is off limits if you can sell it if you
can do it with a smile and get a big
laugh then nothing's off limits it's
about that getting laughter period i
definitely think yeah he's right some
people are going to be offended but if
you if you if you have half the crowd
dying of laughter and the other half
that's amazing that's the that's the
love i forgot which special was
louis ck
anybody could talk the hell with your
race you could talk about anything if
it's funny louis ck special tone i don't
know what the name of it but it was his
n-word joke where he's like he actually
says the full n-word life and he's it
was one of the most brilliant jokes
where he's like well white people got
away with saying the animal because when
you say the n word you're making me say
it in my head he's like why don't you
take responsibility yeah and you say
anything bro you and nothing is off
limits but like he said you got to be
it has to be funny bro it has to be
something where people go oh [ __ ] like
he that's a great written joke so any
rate through the middle eastern i could
talk about anybody you know what i mean
anything anybody any race any situation
as long as it's personal to me if it's
funny bro people are gonna laugh
i do a lot of the rooms that i do are
predominantly you know african-american
i talk about everything but there's
nothing that i don't talk about pat do
you ask that because you think that
there's certain things that should be
off limits there's certain things you
know that are universally funny like do
you have any strong opinions on like all
right this is certain things they're
completely off limits like talking like
for instance in in uh
ufc
uh what's the kid the guy's name we just
beat moss but all colby covington talk
[ __ ] about dustin poury's wife and kids
like to me that is
i guess that's not off limits but that
is [ __ ] disgusting right but you know
free speech do what you want yeah but
that's different what what that that
does is there's if anybody laughs at
that you're like that yeah i don't know
if that makes sense or not like if if
you think that's funny when kobe says
what he says about dustin or he says
that about
jorge and he says that about all this
stuff
it's just a matter of time until
somebody
like
mazvidal found him into a restaurant and
he comes out and he gets into a fight
you can't say stuff you know i'm telling
you if he says that to the wrong ufc
armenian fighter yeah i'm telling you
it's over for that guy you can't talk
like that to people you just cannot so
set that aside that to me is in a
different category of
um disrespect yeah i don't know where
you want to put that and it's the person
that's doing it right a fighter is one
thing a politician saying something is
another thing like but a comedian
we're supposed to be the ones that are
sort of a little bit responsible for
pushing the limits strategically there
is an article but i think i think you're
you need to be freed if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you